[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEN PERSON: Give me one
minute, and I will show you
how persistent disks are a
great block storage option
for your virtual machine.
Persistent disk is high
performance solid state
and hard disk
drive block storage
that can be attached
to instances
running in Compute Engine
or Google Kubernetes Engine.
Standard persistent
disk, or HDD,
is low cost and best
suited for large data
processing workloads that
primarily use sequential I/Os.
SSDs are better for high
performance apps and databases
that require lower
latency and more IOPS.
You can create persistent
disks through the console
by selecting the disk type
and where you want it.
Then attach it to
the virtual machine.
You could also use the G
Cloud command line interface
to create and attach the disk.
Persistent disks are
located independently
from VM instances,
meaning you can detach
remove disks to keep
your data even after you
delete your instances.
Sharing content is also a snap
since many virtual machines can
read data from a single disk.
And you don't have to worry
about downtime because you
can resize the storage on
demand without having to restart
the VM or reattach the volumes.
For high availability, create
regional storage replicating
and automated
geo-replicated snapshots.
On the security front,
persistent disks
are automatically encrypted
to protect your data.
So next time you're looking
to add reliable and affordable
storage to your
VM, take a minute
and look at persistent disk.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/persistentdisk.